we've heard from the prosecution in the
second impeachment trial of former
president trump
and now it's time for the defense this
is after two days of very intense
arguments by house impeachment managers
lincoln mr linking rather mr trump to
the deadly violence at the capitol on
january 6
and suggesting he may still be dangerous
three republican senators ted cruz mike
lee and lindsey graham
met with the trump legal team yesterday
now that is very unusual why
because they are also jurors in the
trial nicole killian is on capitol hill
nicole the left the last time
the ex-president lawyer spoke to the
senate on tuesday it was not well
received at all so
what do you expect today well gail the
president's
legal team will argue that this trial is
unconstitutional and denies him
due process they described that meeting
last night with republican senators as
friendly even though technically those
same senators are supposed to be
impartial jurors
last night three of the trials jurors
senators ted cruz lindsey graham and
mike lee met with former president
trump's legal team to talk strategy
we were discussing their strategy for
tomorrow
we were sharing our thoughts in terms of
where the argument was and where it
should go
when asked if he was comfortable with
the team's legal strategy cruz said the
end result of the trial
is already clear mr trump will be
acquitted
but other senators are keeping an open
mind you don't make a decision as a
juror until you hear both sides period
end of story house impeachment managers
rested their case declaring the evidence
against former president trump
is clear if you don't find this a high
crime in misdemeanor today
you have set a new terrible standard for
presidential
misconduct in the united states of
america the managers allege the former
president had a pattern of inciting
violence
pointing in part to his lack of
condemnation after supporters swarmed
michigan state capital
and the later uncovering of an alleged
plot to kidnap the governor
we got to get her going i don't think
she likes me too mom
and asked senators if they would risk
giving mr trump the opportunity to
incite violence again would you bet the
lives of more police officers on that
would you bet the safety of your family
on that today former president trump's
legal team
will counter by showing video of
prominent democrats allegedly making
inciting statements to bolster their
argument
that the language mr trump used during
his rally is protected
we fight like hell it's a powerful
speech but when
he uses the word fight most of the times
during the case it's clear he's talking
about
legislators fighting for our rights mr
trump's lawyers are only expected to
take a few hours for their presentation
and could wrap their case
today which means it's possible there
could be a vote in this trial
as early as this weekend anthony nicole
thank you